hello and welcome to this video playing
kick the national a second something
thomas cartons can't ants Wow hello
didn't know once they don't know this
guy all right new green fraud there
should be six is currently and all the
rage but not played here ok hmm i don't
know this variation and probably you
will get the pawn back but we'll see
normally the pawn is recovered with
between 85 and then can we take c5 and
here it seems it's not in a hurry to get
it back maybe 97 let the idea
I wants to go die to e4 problem name
okay I'm 95 then if I guess is success
you for
please it anyway okay so you must have
calculated something great here night f7
what is the deal night rock before or
something like that
take their it's a closing material or
night f7 Ruby oil would be very crazy ok
I can take the bishop on f5 tix and just
recapture I wanted to play Knight f7 but
only now saw Group D for ya five route
64 and I'm sure I can kill not sure if I
can Connecticut better so probably have
to do this
I mean that isn't so bad but it wasn't
it was my plan I'm also porn a p.m.
hmm
some children to clear 95 or something
that's the idea okay cannot go here
probably just back
so I still have the sea point and maybe
not be five was an idea
okay not not sure how good an idea it
was but I could have invested a moment
on that okay highlight age said no was a
pin right if seven wasn't a problem okay
check might be five now
now it will be good on these six
attacking the b7 pawn this is running
into a fork check takes p6 I this ruckus
so off they have three rogue
TX b6 it should should promote this is
the slack nice i'm sitting i did i
really hope i played this correctly with
the pause okay so yeah somewhat strange
opening yeah and I don't know it said in
line I feel like what should be better
with the pony I don't know yeah did this
one and this was very cool I wanted to
do this but then rock deform irritated
me why exactly this irritated me and
somehow all kinds of things are hanging
the engine seized this more which I did
not look it's trapped okay so I but this
is not bad I mean I'm keeping keeping my
poor and there is no problem here here
here 95 also would have been interesting
to consider directly attacking things
but ok I think this is also keeping a
big advantage yeah Bishop c4 was better
ok check so maybe this isn't such a
clear thing but ok it is better for
white then it wants to go p 8 and this
means I'm better if he has to pass up
the defense
on this doesn't work due to the game
continuation I think the chest makes is
six men and white wins yeah I'm
promoting a pawn now this this happy
seven and just just too late so here c7
and to see pong promotes yeah so
typically difficult technical play all
of the Greenfeld but probably this this
line a way he allowed this position here
we write as the extra point is not
completely reliable for black okay well
thanks for watching